I am also fed up with animal abuse,
of his grandfather
and of the people they say are just animals.
It's just a dog
as Judge Esteban Salinas wolver
which seeks to reduce the judgment
historical 10-year imprisonment
for the Hatos and tango repertoire,
dogs,
rescuers ands.
He wants to destroy the precedent
that this ruling marked at the national level
and we will not allow it.
See you this January 28th at the Plaza de Armas
at 10:00 a.m.
in Querétaro.
Please help me to share and disseminate this video.
so that all of us who love animals
let us be the voice of all those who do not have it.
We are going to march and demand respect for the law,
judgment and animal rights.
Respect the law,
their lives are worth